156 millones de dólares en yates y
mansiones ese es el botín que la policía
italiana tiene en su poder desde que
empezó a incautar las pertenencias de
oligarcas rusos como el yate del
propietario del grupo siderúrgico es
severstal alexéi mordashóv la policía
italiana acaba de incautar el lady en un
yate valorado en 65 millones de euros
perteneciente alexéi mordashóv
estacionado en imperial y gurí al
noreste de italia de acuerdo con las
recientes sanciones de la unión europea
la razón de su inscripción en la lista
de sancionados este oligarca
multimillonario está cerca del
presidente ruso vladimir putin después
de alemania y francia italia pasa a la
fase activa de las sanciones de rusia
adoptadas por la unión europea y eeuu la
confiscación de propiedades hace parte
de una estrategia global de presión
sobre esta influyente y poderosa élite
económica la confiscación de propiedades
hace parte de una estrategia global de
presión sobre esta influyente y poderosa
élite económica tornar al ser irracional
'barack esta noche le digo oligarcas
rusos y a los líderes corruptos que
estafan miles de millones de dólares a
este régimen violento no más
eeuu quiero decir el departamento de
justicia de eeuu está reuniendo un grupo
de trabajo dedicado a perseguir los
crímenes de los oligarcas rusos nos
estamos uniendo a los aliados europeos
para encontrar y confiscar sus yates sus
apartamentos de lujo sus aviones
privados vamos a por sus ganancias mal
habidas
en eeuu como en europa a estos grupos de
trabajo dedicados siguen identificando
los activos financieros y bienes que
pertenecen a más de 500 personalidades o
entidades rusas